this is a production of cornell
university
welcome to this floorcast episode on
comparing organic substrates in the last
few years i have noticed an increased
interest from growers in using organic
substrates for growing
flower and vegetable transplants this
begs the question what is an organic
substrate
that is a substrate or potting mix that
is derived from naturally occurring
substances and does not contain
synthetic materials
so many of the ingredients that we
already use in substrates are considered
organic these would include peats and
vermiculite perlite
compost that are prepared according to
nop guidelines
and then organic fertilizers for
certified organic production the
ingredients in an organic substrate must
meet national organic program or nop
guidelines
in all cases an operation should check
with their organic certification agent
so what is not organic about
conventional potting mixes
in this table we list the recipe for the
conventional cornell pete light mix
it calls for half a cubic yard of peat
moss and half a cubic yard of course
vermiculite with some various fertilizer
and wetting agent amendments
the peat moss vermiculite and limestone
are appropriate for organic use but the
synthetic fertilizers triple super
phosphate potassium nitrate and the
micronutrient charge cannot be used as
well the conventional wetting agent
would not be acceptable for organic use
the objective of the trial that i'm
going to talk about that was conducted
with my graduate student stephanie beaks
was to trial several organic substrates
for the growth effects on flour and
vegetable transplants without additional
fertilizers
in the trial we wanted to look at a
range of locally regionally and
nationally available mixes and compare
them to each other
we have noticed that in particular a lot
of the organic vegetable transplant
growers prefer mixes to be pre-loaded
with a lot of nutrients that may carry
the plant for four to six weeks of
growth
therefore in the trial we did not add
additional fertilizer as we wanted to
see how well growth would do using just
the fertility from the mixes themselves
in the trial we took plugs of tomato
pepper pansy petunia and snapdragon
seedlings and we transplanted these in
four inch pots with which had various
organic mixes
these pots were grown on for six weeks
at a fairly warm greenhouse temperature
of 70 degrees fahrenheit
and they were watered daily or as needed
with tap water in the trial we did not
use any additional fertility the
substrates that we used in the trial
included
a cornell organic mix this is one that
we have prepared using a peat perlite
and vermicompost recipe that you can see
here where the vermicompost
is supposed to supply the majority of
the nutrients as well we use dolomitic
limestone to add some calcium and
magnesium and to increase the ph of the
mix
as well as add green sand rock phosphate
and blood meal to add additional npnk
the other substrates that we used in the
trial include sunshine natural and
organic substrates number one and number
four both of these are peat perlite
based substrates with an organic starter
charge
two mixes from the vermont compost
company
one is their fort light which contains
peat their compost
perlite
and several different sources of organic
nutrients as well as their fort v which
is similar to fort light but it does not
contain perlite
we used a locally available
organic mix prepared in upstate new york
that contains peat compost and a poultry
litter fertilizer
then from the hudson valley we trialed
mcenroe organic farm premium light mix
this mix contains compost peat and
perlite as well as several sources of
organic nutrients
finally from sunshine we also trialled
their organic px2 mix which besides peat
and perlite contains quite a bit of bark
as well as composted peanut shells
we tested the ph and the electrical
conductivity of these mixes before
planting
for potting mixes the suggested ph
before planting would be 5.5 to 6.5
of the mixes that we trialed
the sunshine number one and number four
mixes as well as the locally formulated
mix had phs above the suggested range
the cornell and the fort light mixes
were slightly below the suggested range
and the rest of the mixes were within
that suggested range we also tested the
pre-plant electrical conductivity or ec
which is a total measure of the salts
which would include both fertilizer
salts as well as non-fertilizer salts
such as sodium and chloride
of the mixes that we looked at cornell
sunshine number one and sunshine number
four and the local mix
had relatively low saturated media
extract ec values
the px2 was roughly in the normal range
and the fort light the fort v and the
mackin row which were formulated with a
large dose of organic nutrients
came in at the high end of the normal
range
next i will show a series of photos
demonstrating the results of the plant
growth trials after six weeks
for pepper
we noticed that the largest plants were
found with the fort light
the locally prepared mix and macan row
mix
as well the cornell mix and the fort v
mix gave suitable plant growth
the sunshine mixes sunshine 1 and
sunshine 4 and px2 gave fairly small
plant growth and this was expected due
to the low starter nutrient charge that
was added to these mixes tomato gave
similar results and one of the things
that you can note here
low fertility shows as both small plants
such as the sunshine one and four mixes
so one of the take-home messages for
tomato which is a heavier feeder while
we can grow a large plant with some of
these mixes that have a lot of organic
fertilizer incorporated into the
substrate they will eventually run out
of that fertilizer
leading to nitrogen deficiency for pansy
we did not include the px2 mix in this
trial
we noted that the mcenroe the fort v the
fort light and the locally prepared
mixes gave the largest plants
cornell mix the second largest and
sunshine one and number four somewhat
smaller plants
for snapdragon we found that the locally
prepared mix was not at all suitable for
growing snapdragons this was potentially
due to a high ammonium charge
in the compost that was used in that mix
for petunia plants it was a similar
story with the largest plants coming
from
fort v mcenroe fort light as well the
local mix was suitable for petunia
production
medium-sized plants from the
cornell mix
and smaller plants from the sunshine 1
and 4 mixes
one of the things that's very evident
from this picture is that the
new growth of the plants
exhibits iron deficiency from many of
the substrates this shows up as
yellowing between the veins on these
upper leaves
therefore one thing to take into account
when using any potting mix whether it's
conventional or organic
is the starting ph and starting
limestone charge of the mix
depending on your water's alkalinity
you may need to use a mix that has a
lower limestone charge
in the previous trial we noticed that
the sunshine mixes were prepared with
only a starter nutrient charge that is
they were not intended to supply all of
the nutrients
for crop growth therefore we wanted to
test one of the mixes sunshine number
four
and
trial two different organic fertilizer
sources first we conducted a trial with
sustain 844
sustain is a poultry litter and
hydrolyzed feather meal based
certified organic product the other
organic fertility source that we tried
was worm power vermicompost which has a
lower nutrient charge than the sustain
so we used it at higher incorporation
rates we used it at 0 5 10 20 or 30
percent by volume incorporated into the
substrate before transplanting
for the sustained trial we noticed that
for pepper about five pounds per cubic
yard gave the best growth
and any additional
applied sustain did not increase the
amount of growth by the plant
for tomato which is a heavier feeder
we noticed that about 10 pounds per
cubic yard
gave good growth of the plant
in the verma compost trial for tomatoes
which are a heavier feeder
we notice that at least 10 percent of
the vermicompost by volume
and really up to 20 percent
uh gave very nice well-fertilized plants
with less symptoms of nutrient
deficiency
from the trial we came away with several
take-home lessons
one is to check with your supplier to
determine the amount of nutrient charge
in the substrate
is the substrate intended to carry the
plant for four to six weeks from the
fertility that's loaded up into it or is
the fertility that's added intended to
service only a starter charge to carry
the plant for the first week or two
after transplanting
other lessons that we learned
are that we recommend getting a
laboratory media test done on your
materials
before you plant into them
another lesson
is to monitor the electrical
conductivity or the ec this can be done
both pre-planned with the laboratory
media tests or or at home tests
and can also be done throughout the
the growth cycle as well
mix is pre-loaded with heavy nutrients
will have a high ec and you will need to
be careful with salt sensitive seedlings
if you monitor ec throughout the
experiment
a low and decreasing ec is going to
suggest low nutrients and and the amount
of nutrients will be declining over time
finally if you monitor ph over time
this will also be useful we found that
compost and other organic fertilizer
sources such as poultry litter can raise
the p8
a couple final notes are that organic
producers should always consult their
certification agents before purchasing
and using products always conduct your
own in-house trials before using new
materials at full production scale
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu